journalism is one industry that's been
severely disrupted by technology over
the last few years newspapers have
suffered financially as readers have
gone online and many papers have yet to
develop new revenue streams to replace
the old models but now a brand new
startup thinks technology may also be
journalism's Saviour it involves average
citizens buying a share of independent
newsrooms with the help of
cryptocurrency Barry Peterson has the
story to see a corporate owner decimate
the news staff of The Daily News it's
bad for New York City there's nothing
unusual about New York's Mayor Bill
DeBlasio being interviewed what's
different is not the mayor nor even the
journalists but how this kind of
journalism is being funded by a firm
called civil media company whose CEO is
Matthew Isles we've had 20 years or more
of digital media being run primarily by
companies like Google and Facebook that
just do not care about journalism and
have business models that are predicated
on harvesting user data and serving you
ads and it's harming journalism in a
serious way Sybil has now funded online
journalism outlets from Chicago to
Singapore as the footprint of
traditional newspapers is shrinking
civils footprint is growing the goal is
a marketplace for news owned and
operated by journalists and citizens
funded in part by cryptocurrency the
civil token is a consumer token it is a
voting stake on the platform token
holders will have a vote on whom to
publish uncivil and will play a pivotal
role at holding them accountable and the
information is archived using blockchain
decentralized and publicly owned online
storage a way to keep facts in the open
and hackers out the block chains
immutable nature makes it next to
impossible for anyone including
government's corporations billionaires
to be able to essentially hack the
blockchain and change some fact or
record or information in the past
sometimes journalism is referred to as
the first draft of history by using
something like blockchain we
can imprint the first draft of history
into a permanent and immutable archive
this is one of civils first test tube's
a group of seven reporters and three
editors in Denver Colorado who all once
worked at the Denver Post two shared
Pulitzer Prizes for coverage there but
all left
amid cutbacks and layoffs mandated by
its hedge fund owners whose demand for
higher profits decimated the newsroom
now they produced the Colorado Sun
nearly three weeks old with seed money
from civil Lori Rickman is editor of the
Sun so we began those conversations and
I can tell you it was exciting to be
dreaming of building something new
rather than to be collaborating in the
destruction of a proud newspaper I get
dreaming but money accounts do they help
you with the money as well yes money
does counts civil has been very generous
with us so far they provided enough
runway to get up and and make our case
that the people of Colorado because at
the end of the day you know we're not
going to be able to count on civil to
finance us forever and ever the Sun has
reported on how Colorado's governor
formed a pact as a possible run for
president a climber
remaking his life after a devastating
fall and a dozen surgeries and a piece
on the South Platte River reported by
Kevin Simpson on this day he was doing
interviews for his story much like he
did as a veteran reporter for the Denver
Post where he spent 33 years and battled
cancer there are a few differences he
works from a home office not a newsroom
and another big change the job is fun
again
hi as this energized re-energized you to
be a journalist it absolutely has it's
it's the difference between working for
somebody else and working for yourself
this is our baby
it will arise or fall on our efforts and
that is energizing it's also a little
frightening but overall it's it's just a
great feeling but journalism is
expensive and the son insist on
paying reporters real salaries you know
we're all passionate about journalism
but we all have have lives and mortgages
and rent to pay and kids in college and
all of those kinds of things and we're
very fortunate in that the Colorado Sun
has been able to provide all of us with
salaries that are comparable to what we
were making at the Denver Post or in
some cases even more than we earned at
the Denver Post to pay its way as civil
funding tapers off it will depend on
community and corporate sponsors for now
we really are using more of a national
public radio public television kind of
model which is to say to a company we're
not going to help you sell mattresses or
the fourth of July or Washington's day
or something like that but if you
believe in our mission and you believe
in in our company then we would be happy
to have your support journalists have
become accustomed to reporting bad news
about their struggling profession if
civil works in Colorado and elsewhere it
may be a rare moment for reporters these
days a story about journalism with a
happy ending for CBS this morning
Saturday Barry Petersen Denver I like
the sound of that yeah so encouraging
and and particularly for local news
which has been so hard hit by what's
happening in journalism rethinking the
way that you do things yeah